hi my name is Jason Abernathy and I'm a
front-end developer at Wolfram research
I am here to present the attach saw
interface which is a feature which
allows you to build better user
interfaces
my name is Jason Abernathy I am a
front-end developer I deal with a Linux
front-end and I'm gonna be talking about
the attached cell interface which is
something that's been baking for a while
in the front-end and we use internally
but is something we want to bring out
eventually into the system context and
and we'd like to garner get some
feedback from you guys and help us to
find out where we can improve it so
let's start off by talking about user
interface design and start with a rather
assertive comment saying dialog windows
are going away in favor of contextual
menus there seems to be a bit of a
reclamation of screen space I don't know
if that's being pushed by users or if
it's something that is being pushed on
users by user interface designers but
you'll notice that like for example Mac
removing the scroll bar that happened on
Linux - they think it seems to be a new
thing where if you don't need a control
then it should just not be drawn and so
that is a so if if you have an interface
that's bold with like a palette or a
dialog that real estate is gonna be used
up you're not gonna be able to get it
back until you close the window but you
might have need to use something that
was on it and so you're constantly
battling with whether or not you need to
keep it open or closed and also dialog
boxes they can if they're not relevant
to what you're trying to edit at a time
they can just have too many options and
I was going to show the basic basic math
assistant I didn't want to call out any
particular dialogue but this oh I just
realized I'm not in full-screen here you
guys were so polite nobody said anything
yes of course
there we go okay all right sorry about
that
yeah so if you'll I love them the math
assistant when I first used Mathematica
I got my first copy number of years ago
during my undergrad and I loved seeing a
typesetting menu all the different ways
you can make it create the subscripts
and superscripts and things like that
but if you don't actually need to have
all that out at once and you're not
interested in typesetting so you want to
just add options to graphics for example
maybe I can bring this up here it's just
a lot so yeah so maybe we can do better
maybe we have other ways of designing
user interfaces that are very specific
to the things we want to want to do Lou
just talked about manipulating dynamic
modules this is a great way of creating
user interface that is local to the
thing that you want to edit for example
here I have a graphics 3d with a sphere
in it and I have a nice input field
where I can write a name so as you hear
and I can change the lighting one
disadvantage though to this approach
yeah well actually I can think of a
couple one is that the thing the
graphics 3d sphere that's on the inside
there it's coupled strongly with the
user interface so let's see if I can
find okay I'll open up the cell where I
define the interface and you see that
the thing that I model the thing that I
want to manipulate is just this very
small part of the expression and all of
the rest is pretty much the the
controller here and also the options for
the sphere have been tightly coupled to
the manipulate so for example if I want
to close this up again if I want to copy
the sphere and email it friend say hey
look at this cool sphere I have I can do
that that works
but they can't edit it the same way that
I've edited it and also if you open it
up like Lee said there's a dynamic
module box in there so it's still in a
way thinks that it's inside user
interface so it's not like you're
editing it and you get a pure object
when you're when you're done so that
idea of strongly coupled strongly
coupled model I guess what the
controller is something that we'd like
to avoid okay okay so I didn't need to
rag on the user interface too bad but I
did I think this is the part of the
speech or the the where I say we have a
better way or we think we're starting to
get a better way and that better way is
just by letting people attach cells to
things in the front end so here we have
a cell that has a rectangle box with a
little bit of text in it just by
pressing this button here you can attach
a cell to it and what it means by having
a cell attached to it is this this
little cell over here that also has a
rectangle box it will move with this
this parent cell as it scrolled but
otherwise it's not part of the notebook
at all like if you do a notebook get on
this notebook you're not going to see
this attached cell anywhere in the
notebook is very ephemeral so it doesn't
it doesn't stick around if you save the
notebook and you open it up again
now the type of cells not going to be
there and and that's such a simple
concept but because cells are so
powerful yeah you know just that's the
main one of the main expression handling
things in the front end or in the
notebook sorry
trying to turn away from my mic since
it's one of the mean it you know you can
put anything in a cell so you can build
some pretty great things if you if you
type cells to other objects so I'll show
you how you do that oh I sorry before
I'll do that I'll tell you how we use in
the front end so I mentioned that is
something we've been using the front
and whether you know it or not you've
been interacting with it
so the code assist menu if you see that
there that is actually an attached cell
and when you press the button on it it
opens up another attached cell and so
that's a cell that's been attached to I
don't know if is attached to the cell or
to the to the box the image editor which
unfortunately only comes up well it will
come up in the working environment so
the image editor that's another thing
the toolbar there is implemented with an
attached cell as well as the predictive
interface which let's see there it is
there so that's also implemented within
tabs all so you can see these attached
cells have lots of content they have
lots of buttons pulldown menus and
things like that disturb my slide show
again all right
one other thing the cell group opener I
don't know if you guys have ever seen
that before this is actually a tab cell
as well it's a cell that's been attached
to the end of the content area of that
cell and it contains a button so he's a
the idea of using attached cells to make
user interface elements is pretty
powerful good question oh the dad Doc's
that solved the top there that's an
attached soul I didn't know it's a dog
though okay actually I did learn about a
few other things that I didn't know were
attached cells but that's a dog soul
okay how to use it well as I mentioned
earlier this thing is still baking so
currently you can only access the
functionality by calling directly into
the front end packet handler but for the
purpose of this presentation we're going
to define our own function for doing
that just keep things simple so you see
it just passes the arguments right into
B right into the handler there and
evaluate it so we can use it and now we
will use it so the first and second
arguments of the packet or which is now
our function are the first one will be
the parent so the thing that we want to
attach to and the second argument will
be the cell that we want to attach to
the parent and so if we evaluate that we
see a nice little spiky oh maybe I
should have explained what this does so
we were saying we want to attach it to
the cell that's doing the evaluation and
we're gonna get we're going to attach
spiky so here we see a little spiky
there it's been attached to that cell
and it will scroll with it we also see
that the function returns a reference to
the attached cell so that's that cell
object there and when we're done with it
if we like we can just call notebook
and it goes away and it gets cleaned up
nicely too so if you have dynamics
dynamics in there it all happens nicely
some other things you can do or some
other parameters to this function I so
third and fourth arguments they are a
lot like the arguments to inset so they
tell you how you want to position the
attached cell relative to the parent
okay so I'm just evaluate a temporary
function here and all it's going to do
is attach it attach a cell I don't know
why it says failed but this is spiky to
the evaluation notebook at the position
that we give it so you'll see here
you'll see here that will attach spiky
to the bottom of this notebook and we
will align the bottom of the attached
cell with it I didn't mention that the
parent anchor is prefixed by an offset
if you say automatic it it it just means
there will be no offset you can all
there are other other other key words to
it but generally it's an offset so if we
just evaluate this we see we've got
spiky at the bottom okay and I don't
think I left I hope that doesn't stick
around the whole time I must have gotten
rid of the oh yeah thank you
we don't want that to stick around oh
you know what because because of that
option there that I'll be telling you
about in the future okay false alarm
all right what else we got here so a few
examples of how the offset is used so
you see we're going to attach spiky to
the bottom on the right at the bottom
bury the notebook then we're going to
scale toward the center so the parameter
that is the offset is signed
so negative means go toward the center
of the object and positive means going
away so here we are aligning the center
of the
of spiky with the bottom right of the
notebook and then four that's that's for
the first cell for the second one we're
going to be moving inward both
directions by 20% because as a scaled
coordinate and then for the third one
we're gonna be moving in by 20% and then
100 units up and to the left toward the
center okay
positioning the purpose of this slide
was just to show you that if you're
attaching things to the notebook
they do not scroll there so they're
attached to the to the notebook window
so if you think you want to attach it
all the way at the bottom the notebook
so it disappears unless you scroll down
there that's not gonna happen on the
other hand though things that are
attached to cells and boxes they will
scroll so they're there more tightly
bound to to the m2 those objects alright
now what can we do with this thing I did
not mean to leave that so open so for
now I will just delete it all right how
do you how do you build any user
interface with this
well the main way of communicating from
the width the parent from the child or
getting information about the parent is
by using attach cell parent function so
if you have any controls and you want to
control something that a property or
option and the parent you can use things
like this like current value tab saw
parent so current value takes a
reference object as the first parameter
and then the second one is the is the
option name and it can be used as the
left-hand side of of a lot like of of
whatever object you're referring to so
because it can be used as a left-hand
side it can be used inside controls such
as sliders and setter bars and and and
things like that
so here I've created a small panel that
has a color setter and all it's doing
the color setter is going to change the
background of whatever at the attach saw
parent is as well as the margins so I
can evaluate that I think this is
probably one of the easiest ways of
showing how it cells are attached and
now I'm going to use my attached cell
command and we will attach this to this
cell here we still need to find a way to
reference the parent object which can be
a little bit tricky with box objects but
for cells you can use the use the cells
command to find a list of Salzmann
notebook and here I've just said give me
the first cell that has the tag example
cell 2 which is this one here and so we
see if we attach this cell with the
interface there it is there so it was it
was lining up the bottom of the cell
with the top sorry the bottom of the
parent with the top to type cell and the
controls work as expected so we can
change the background we can change the
margins but also got a reset button
there that just sets the evalu to
inherited and again we've returned
reference to the tab cell so when we
want to rid of it we can just call
notebook delete now one thing I want to
point out is there was no real coupling
between the between the model so for
example that would have been the cell
and the user interface in that example
other than that keyword attached all
parent so that's really useful because
it means that you can attach the cell to
whatever you want and it will operate on
on objects that aren't normally they
aren't written explicitly to be
manipulated so that's a really nice
feature of using these attached cells
and especially the types all parent
command now it would be really annoying
if you had to constantly call notebook
delete on your on your tab cells and
obviously you don't have to do that with
the suggestion bar and the image editor
so I've got you know manually removing
so
would not be so good but we have a way
of automatically removing them and
that's within another option which I'll
show you now so I'm gonna revisit the
example I showed the beginning that had
a sphere editor in a in a manipulate and
now I'll show you an extra option to an
attached cell the attached cell function
or the packet called closing actions and
closing actions accepts a list of
dismissal criteria and any of which are
satisfied and a attach saw will be
automatically destroyed so for this case
and this is a very common commonly used
one selection departure if the object
that you're interacting with you move
the selection away from that then the
attached cell will be deleted so that's
how the suggestion bar for example it
automatically disappears when you click
away and here I've just thrown it thrown
into event handler on the sphere so that
when you click on it the cell is
attached so here we are we click on it
to attach the cell and it's a attached
to the bottom there and just like before
you can give it a name prefix here and
we can change the lighting and when we
click away there goes our type cell and
if we look at the expression here or we
command shift E and we look at the
object okay we have the event handler
but there's no dynamic box there saying
that this thing was set up to be
manipulated other than the event handler
which I admit is a bit of a something
that needs to be addressed there are
other ways you can automatically cells
automatically deleted there's an
exciting list there with with all of the
conditions most of them are
self-explanatory so I'll save that for
now I and as I mentioned the beginning
you can put anything in these cells so I
thought I'd end on a bang and show that
even things like animates and and things
like that will work when they're
attached so
if you have any whatever you can think
of that you can put in a normal cell you
can put it in entire cell so that's all
I have for now if you have any
suggestions like I said this is still
baking so let me know or although that
link to which will probably like you
email our suggest or file a suggestion
report with with Wolfram or you can just
come up to me if you have any questions
or comments during the conference or
email me directly so thanks for your
time
[Applause]